impressionnant le décollage du bien
combat polyvalent que l'armée française
vient de commander à 40 exemplaires et
dont le vol de démonstration à marquette
cérémonie d'inauguration du salon du
bourget ce matin on ne savait d'ailleurs
pu très bien qui était la véritable
vedette entre le président jacques
chirac et les deux ministres
cohabitation nist à l'ats richard conte
la défense et jean paul coussot pour les
transports ils avaient tous prévenus à
l'avancé tant que le premier ministre
lionel jospin n'aurait pas fait sa
déclaration de politique générale
pas question de faire la moindre annonce
sur des sujets aussi brûlants que
thomson csf et à réformer
ou celle des argonautes alors la visite
a surtout été l'occasion de passer en
revue quelques-uns des 1800 exposants
originaires que 43 m
et de s'informer sur quelques détails
techniques parfois un peu compliqué
traduction il c'était la présentation
des fusées de la compagnie chinoise la
grande muraille de chine qui espèrent
grignoter le marché d'arianespace cela
et 220 aéronefs sol ou en vol de
démonstration sera visible par le public
dès 9h30 demain matin ainsi que le week
end du 21 et 22 juin
la semaine du 16 au 20 étant réservé aux
professionnels
tout le monde attend désormais la venue
de lionel jospin ici même qui dans une
semaine devrait faire connaître la
nouvelle politique de son gouvernement
en matière d'aéronautique et d'espacé